well I'll tell you this this one story  little quick and and I'll get off of  here and the real reason we're here is  you but I got that call from pop every  year I watched it draft I sit at home I  tell everybody all day long I'm not  watching the draft and I'm not going to  do this I sit at home I watch the draft  and we pick people that I've never heard  of sitting there Emanuel Jinnah Billy  [Applause]  who did we just pick oh yeah these these  can be great he's this he's okay pop  whatever you know okay whatever he shows  up two years later and I actually don't  remember him being hurt  I remember him showing up in the gym and  we're playing pickup in the summertime  and